we've been in the car Michael like the
beat so he played back and back and
forth he'd be in the car jamming 50 Cent
In the Club he'd be like boom boom
but the only problem when Michael
started singing the words that's when I
had a problem I could be like you see me
in the club with about a foot above like
Michael Michael no no don't say that
because I like it Chris
I love 50 Cent crew
did you ever see him in person yeah we
look
it was a dude named Christian artigay
then he was a boss he he would spend
like three four hundred thousand dollars
to have you come perform like three
songs it'd be me Michael Jackson whoever
else whoever else and Michael Jackson
Trailer was right next to mine and we
was blowing like a broke stove and Mike
opened a curtain and looked over and
said hey
I said you want to have something
no thank you
[Music]
would have movie night on Tuesday night
and you would go there and all the stars
like you you I'd see I saw uh Steve and
Edie Gourmet Lucille Ball and you know
Michael would be there he was behind the
door at first because it was too many
people there's too many people in the
room he was hiding behind the door
they went behind the door and we were
standing behind the door and I was like
yeah
there's so many people in here
he loved Rick Ross you like that noise
Rick Ross said her we like that dog
he'd be saying that he wouldn't even
admitted he was saying it because I
heard him say it one time and I was like
Michael you hear that he was like I know
I didn't hear that
I don't know who that was Chris
I said I thought it was you I called him
one time he's like her I said Mike I saw
your nose you man he said I'm sorry I
love Maybach Music Chris I'm sorry
to make a long story short Prince steps
off the stage and plays the bass in
Michael Jackson's face rips the freaking
basins 10 different pieces Michael
Jackson leaves and goes home and says
leave me in the house for breakfast so I
go to his house for breakfast knock on
the door first words he says where was
Prince playing the bass in my face
but Michael Jackson used to have that
ability too he'd push you again you know
and you'd be working and
he'd come and go no I love that I love
what you're doing it's great it's
wonderful now I need you to dig really
deep
and go somewhere you've never gone
before you know I think where where do
we need to go yeah you're right I ain't
going in deep enough let me start
digging
and you do it then you hand it to him he
says that's great now I need to dig a
little bit
return to Michael Jackson he was not on
that song at all no that was not
[Applause]
then you got it gotta got to make your
mind up
[Applause]
first I'd like to thank um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wait what am I doing and Michael was so
famous he had to disguise himself and we
would come downstairs I'd be like
where's Michael Michael be covered up
like I'm over here Chris from here
Michael that's you yeah Chris so we go
into movies and we're thinking you know
I'm trying to be secret too you know I'm
having myself in Michael laughing louder
than anybody everybody know Michael's
laughing
[Laughter]
the song never came out nah I got it I'm
gonna give it to you for your birthday
[Applause]
Kenny Ortega who directed High School
Musical um was friends with Michael and
uh he talked a lot about him right and
I like idolized Michael since I was a
little boy Kenny knew that one time I
was at dinner in France with the cast of
high school music and Kenny got a phone
call from the other end of the table and
he answers it and then he looks at me
from across the table and I just know
something's up I don't know what's up
but he goes
I got somebody who wants to talk to you
and he goes in like come here Zach he
pulls me over and puts me on the phone
and I was like hello and I heard hi
who's this
and I was like this is Zac Efron and I'm
a massive fan and I'm an actor and like
my hero and I didn't know what to say I
was I was just at a loss for words and
uh rambling on and then he said that's
really nice can you hand the phone back
to Kenny to Middle East
you know that's [__] up I like Michael
you know
Michael say you want more kids but he
ain't into having sex which I can
believe because he seems kind of weird
that way
but he got to be doing something because
you don't make the noises on the album
this [__] make
without playing with your Jimmy Jam
and as gross as it sounds to say as
seeing Michael Duo would be crazy
because Mike wouldn't just do it like a
normal person he'd make it hot like a
music video like might come in his house
kick the door in
[Music]
[__]
[Laughter]
laughs
[Music]
first of all I'd like to say
to all the people in the world
that over the years I have dealt with
totally false allegations and I'd like
to take this opportunity to sing a song
to all the children
in the world Mike stars singing
homie
like a river Jordan
foreign
[Music]
Carry Me
like you were my brother
love me like a mother
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry Timmy
[__] y'all y'all know he would do that
y'all know